this video is brought to you by skill
share the first 500 people to sign up
with the link in the description will
get a 2 month free trial hey why is cry
Jared again today we're talking about an
insanely popular Halloween horror series
guaranteed to make you barf up all your
hands porn no not the emoji movie we're
talking saw since 2004 the torture porn
II franchise has been locking up morally
dubious characters in all kinds of
gruesome steel contraptions and
inventing creative new places to hide
the keys it's right before your eyes the
creepy puppet master of the Saw
franchise is jigsaw and boy does he love
playing games and by playing games we
mean locking unconscious people inside
dank warehouses and giving them 60
seconds to choose between certain death
self-mutilation or if they're lucky
disemboweling a stranger when people
talk about saw they tend to focus on
jigsaws impressive body count but just
as you can pick through a pit of heroin
syringes to find the hidden key you can
sit through this villains deadly traps
to find the grander meaning of his games
welcome this wisecrack edition on the
philosophy of saw and as always spoilers
ahead the philosophy of saw all comes
down to jigsaws motivation his torturous
games are opportunities for his victims
to repent for their sins and ostensibly
to transform into better human beings
[Applause]
if they survived his tests and the odds
are not quite ever in their favor
he believes they'll emerge with a
newfound ability to appreciate life so
basically if Tony Robbins had a baby
with Satan in a sense jigsaw embodies a
kind of extremist Christian morality but
before we get there we first need to get
into the headspace of John Kramer alias
the jigsaw killer
once upon a time John was a perfectly
nice civil engineer who loved hanging
out with his pregnant wife Jill who
owned a drug rehab clinic then one of
Jill's tweaked-out patients Cecil Adams
Rob's her clinic accidentally injuring
Jill in the process she suffers a
miscarriage and John falls into a deep
depression a short while after he's
diagnosed with a brain tumor and
terminal cancer he plummets further into
depression and his relationship with
Jill quickly deteriorates let's review
girl loves boy boy loves girl boy gets
girl pregnant girl loses baby boy turns
into a serial killer and instead of
joining tinder or something Jill
continues to entangle herself in her
foods drama after an all-around year
John tries to kill himself by driving
off a cliff miraculously he survives the
crash and emerges totally sure of his
new calling dispensing morality one
torture device at a time moment I
decided to end my life what started me
in my work and brought meaning to it and
I was determined to spend the rest of
dusting the fabric of human nature as
John cooked up a fresh coat of morality
to match his new mission in life he
seems to have been inspired by an
unlikely source early Christian
philosophy specifically its views on
suffering according to early Christian
tradition God is good in everything he
created is good and nobody really
questioned that until one day an early
Christian stubbed his toe and discovered
suffering and was like this sucks
WTF God once a bunch of Christian
theologians started stuffing their toes
they realized they needed to rationalize
how an all good God could have created
such suffering they theorized that
suffering had to be the fault of no good
lousy humans here's what they figured
when Adam ate that Apple from the tree
of knowledge thus committing the
original sin he separated dumb evil
humans from the pure perfect God who
apparently doesn't like it when humans
eat a fresh healthy snack from then on
sinful humans would need to suffer and
repent if they wanted to be reunited
with God suffering then is the result of
our own sins and an expression of the
pain we feel over our separation from
God in this way traditional Christianity
justified suffering as the fault of the
sinner not of God
crisis averted similarly jigsaw thinks
his victims deserve the suffering that
they endured in his traps he helpfully
reminds each victim of the sins they've
committed to get there and he doesn't
hold back as jigsaw sees it his victims
are enslaved by their past immorality
not his industrial-strength
torture devices much like theologians
believed humanity had been trapped by
Adam and Eve's original sin fittingly
the Saw series has a few atoms of its
own in saw four we learned that drug
addict Cecil Adams is responsible for
Jill's miscarriage his original sin is a
catalyst for John's transformation into
jigsaw additionally in the first film
Adams Stan height a photographer who
spends his days spying on people becomes
one of jigsaws targets his professional
quest for seedy knowledge mirrors that
of Adams desire to eat from the tree so
Kramer's view on human suffering shares
a similar origin story to that of early
Christians which hey could mean that
watching Saw movies qualifies as
attending chair
however John Kramer also shares a common
thread with Christian theorist and
father of existentialism Soren
Kierkegaard who sees suffering as a
critical part of personal and spiritual
growth for context much like Kramer
Kierkegaard had his share of should be
luck
he had a lifelong physical deformity
watched his mother brothers and sisters
die at a young age and became totally
convinced that he was going to die at
age 33 like Kramer he also broke up with
the love of his life his then fiancee
regime yet continued to pine after her
for the rest of his days basically the
two of them could have shared stories
over whisky they also both believe that
suffering purifies the sufferer teaches
them to appreciate life and forces them
to take responsibility for their actions
you might prefer your life without a
generous dose of suffering but here the
guy out Kierkegaard believed that an
individual must pass through three
distinct phases to become his or her
true self first the aesthetic driven by
sensual pleasures and lacking any
morality second the ethical driven by
morality and belief in individual
responsibility and third the religious
driven by faith in God so how do you go
from being a lowly drunk-ass thief to an
upstanding ethical guy well you can
always try out one of jigsaws torture
machines that's right according to
Kierkegaard suffering is key to moving
up to the next stage of human
development Kierkegaard was mostly
talking about spiritual and existential
suffering not being caught in a torture
device or worse having people spoil Game
of Thrones still jigsaws machines can be
understood as a test for each of his
victims who are typically athletes
driven by desires for sex drugs or money
his test presents his victims with an
ethical quandary that usually forces
them to make a painful decision this
matches the weiqi regard explains the
journey from being an aesthetic to
ethical being first the ethical life
makes the sufferer suffer even more than
before drawing him out of the frying pan
and into the fire so that he really has
something to scream about and only then
does it help him but how exactly does
suffering help you become more ethical
according to Kierkegaard suffering
forces a human to reflect on their
situation if only to think oh this sucks
that moment of reflection summons the
first doubt which Kierkegaard describes
as the thought why is this happening to
me can it not be otherwise or to put
more simply that little WTF moment
generates the immediate desire to change
your circumstance this desire opens a
person up to a character Gard calls
ethical self understanding suffering is
growth inducing because it turns the
single individual over to himself
completely and its most successful this
suffering can force a person to repent
for past sins take responsibility for
his guilt and choose to seek his own
survival but more on that later
as you progress up the ladder of
development a piece of your old false
self dies much like the old Taylor Swift
judging from his own interpretation of
his car crash John Kramer agrees a
different person called out of the
wreckage for Kierkegaard the ultimate
goal of spiritual suffering is to
completely kill off your flawed false
self in order to make room for your
recreation into a better truer self
Kramer demands this of his most fervent
follower Amanda when she agrees to live
by his ethical code
[Music]
to go down
there is no turning back do you
understand that manda sits in a prayer
like position listening deeply diehard
Sal fans call this scene Amanda's
baptism which is fitting when you
consider how baptism relates to
suffering just as Jesus rose from the
dead to redeem humanity human beings are
baptized and reborn spiritually cleanse
Christian tradition also sees suffering
as a mechanism for spiritual cleansing
jigsaw frequently references this
concept of rebirth whether he's chatting
with his favorite disciple or welcoming
a new victim into one of his traps
welcome to your rebirth tonight I give
you the opportunity to face your
obsession jigsaw even loses his
kidnapping virginity during a literal
celebration of rebirth the Chinese New
Year celebration because it's the year
of the pig Kraemer even picks up his
sweet trademark pig mask at the event
sugar garden jigsaw have a few other
important ideas in common specifically
they both value personal responsibility
Kierkegaard writes that the first
indispensable step of becoming a real
man isn't getting strange new body hair
but by becoming a responsible individual
before God Kraemer demands the same from
his victims
and what's the key to taking
responsibility making a choice
Kramer Spurs his victims into
life-affirming action it seems to me
that the knowledge of your son's
impending death is causing you to act
forgive all his sins to wipe the slate
clean why is it that were you willing to
do that when a life is at stake in the
moment of making a choice Kierkegaard
believed a man becomes himself
similarly Kramer is adamant that his
victims choose their actions even ending
each of his games with this yoda-like
refrain
he also maintains that the individual is
responsible for the outcome of their
decision within the confines of the game
I've never murdered anyone in my life
the decisions are up to them while many
horror films offer an ultimate salvation
SAW does not offer any kind of hope for
a better tomorrow instead it seems to
critique this extreme version of
traditional Christian morality
throughout the series Kramer's positions
as a god-like figure monk or even martyr
he dresses in a long black hooded cape
acquires flocks of disciples and
performed baptisms he also maintains a
quality of omniscience he's always
watching his victims through camera
monitors or people's so jigsaw may be a
god-like figure but he's a seriously
failed one his attempt to establish a
moral order does not bring about the
meaningful change that Kramer professes
it will for starters most of his victims
fail their tests they crumble under
pressure or can't withstand the pain
those who do pass are frequently
traumatized bunch of bull you want to
know the best thing that happened to me
after having to cut off my own arm
is handicap parking damn mall further
revealing the full extent of jigsaws
failure is his ill-fated quest for the
right apprentice each of his contenders
twist his philosophy while jigsaw
creates games that are truly winnable if
you follow the rules you can choose to
preserve your life as long as you're
willing to park with say your left are
his mentees on the other hand create
rigged games that are unwinnable death
traps game if Jake's last game was to
get out his disciples just used the
games to get revenge on people they
don't like eventually they all end up
trapping and killing one another out of
jealousy to them the point of the games
is punishment rather than renewal so
much for jigsaws legacy the characters
in the Saw films frequently remind the
audience that this is a seriously flawed
moral code you said you wanted to talk
then you said you wanted to play a game
you're talking but it means nothing just
before her death
Amanda denounces him nobody lastly
because jigsaw is presented as a
god-like figure you would expect that
his justice be dispensed fairly but it's
not he's the villain of the series and
his morality lessons frequently
sacrifice innocent human lives
similarly you'd expect his death to
result in salvation or redemption but
instead he dies after offering one of
his victims Jeff the opportunity to
forgive him instead Jeff violently kills
Kramer even Kramer's own death is the
result of one of his tests ultimate
failures and he didn't even get to eat a
tasty delicious Apple so much for
finding spiritual rebirth in a reverse
bear trap still plenty of us seemed to
find value in less intensive experiences
of suffering just look at marathon
runners or competitive hot dog eaters so
when it comes to self-improvement is it
no pain no gain or will human suffering
be eliminated once we invent the perfect
dual purpose food delivery and TV
streaming out let us know what you think
in the comments thanks for watching guys
thanks for watching wisecrack we love
making videos for y'all and you guys
often ask what programs we use to do it
and how we learn to use them like many
youtubers a bunch of us at wisecrack are
self-taught and these days you can learn
just about anything online ever wanted
to start a project or learn a new skill
but weren't sure where or how to begin
well Skillshare has got your back
Skillshare is an online learning
community with over 17,000 professional
and easy-to-understand classes in design
photography business and much more
whether you're already a creator or
you're looking to learn how to become
one you'll find like-minded people with
steps and advice on how to take your
ideas to the next level you can take
classes on everything from how to design
an effective logo to the basics of 3d
printing to the proper way to chop
vegetables and if you've got some skills
you'd like to share with the community
you can teach your own class a premium
membership starts at just $10 a month to
get you unlimited access to the full
range of courses but the first 500
people to click the link in the
description will receive a two month
free trial to skill share and all its
resources so head over to sk l dot s h
slash wisecrack to to begin your two
month free trial and get learning you
can download their mobile app and take
classes no matter where you are we can't
wait to see what y'all create and don't
forget to subscribe and ring that bell
to keep up with what we're creating
thanks for watching guys catch y'all
next time peace
[Music]